vamos a resolver algunos problemas de
desigualdades que tienen truco a lo
mejor has de pensar que casi todos los
problemas de desigualdades tienen truco
y si hasta cierto sentido tienes razón
bueno el problema que vamos a resolver
es este queremos encontrar los valores
de x para los cuales x menos 1 dividido
entre x más 2 x más 2 es mayor que 0
vamos a ver dos formas en las cuales se
puede resolver esto para mí la primera
es un poco más simple pero bueno te voy
a contar las dos formas y ya tú eliges
cuál cuál es la que más se te acomoda la
primera forma se basa en el siguiente
hecho qué sucede si queremos que una
fracción sea positiva es decir qué pasa
si tenemos números a ive de modo que
entre b es mayor que 0 que es lo que
tiene que ocurrir bueno utilizando la
ley de los signos tanto el numerador
como el denominador deben ser positivos
o bien ambos deben ser negativos déjame
poner esto así voy a poner una flecha
para acá y otra flecha para acá y lo voy
a escribir de este lado para que la
fracción sea positiva tiene que
suceder que sea mayor que 0 y que b sea
mayor que 0 el numerador y el
denominador mayores que 0 o bien debe
suceder que sea menor que cero
y ve sea menor que 0 b sea menor menor
que cero entonces aquí hay un verdad
déjame ponerle aquí un o tiene que
suceder esto o bien tiene que suceder
esto en cualquiera de las dos
situaciones nos queda que la fracción es
positiva bueno vamos a utilizar esta
idea para resolver el problema de esta
forma si queremos que la expresión x
menos uno entre x más 2 sea mayor que 0
tiene que suceder una de dos cosas o
bien déjame ponerlo en color rojo o bien
tiene que suceder que x menos 1 sea
mayor que 0
x 2 x 2 sea mayor que 0 o déjame ponerlo
aquí 1
y voy a hacer el otro caso aquí a la
derecha o el numerador y el denominador
ambos son negativos es decir x menos uno
es menor que cero y x2 x más 2 es menor
que cero sale en este caso queda
positivo entre positivo que es positivo
y aquí queda negativo entre negativo que
también es positivo bueno vamos a
resolver cada uno de estos casos deja de
empezar con el caso de la izquierda si
sabemos que x menos 1 es mayor que 0
sumando uno de ambos lados obtenemos que
x es mayor
x es mayor que 1 esto viene de la
desigualdad de acá y sabiendo que x + 2
es mayor que 0 podemos restar 2 de ambos
lados y obtenemos que x
es mayor que menos 2 entonces obtenemos
estas dos condiciones para x x mayor que
1 y x mayor que menos 2 vale lo voy a
poner aquí abajo
necesitamos que x sea mayor que 1 y que
x sea mayor que menos 2 pero observa qué
sucede nos están pidiendo que x sea
mayor que 1 y mayor que menos 2 pero
para que las dos condiciones se cumplan
basta con que x sea mayor que 1 lo voy a
escribir aquí abajo
basta con que x sea mayor que 1 si un
número es mayor que 1 automáticamente es
mayor que menos 2 pero al revés no
sucede de verdad esta condición no es
suficiente por sí misma mira vamos a
tomar un número vamos a tomar por
ejemplo x igualados si lo ponemos x
igualados nos queda 2 menos uno o sea 1
entre 2 más 2 que que es 4 nos quedaría
un cuarto y en efecto un cuarto es mayor
que 0 muy bien entonces toda esta cadena
de pensamiento de la izquierda nos lleva
a que x es mayor
1 vamos ahora con el lado derecho en el
lado derecho nos dicen que x menos uno
es menor que cero x menos uno es menor
que cero sumando uno de ambos lados nos
queda que x es menor que 1 entonces esta
es una de las condiciones que se deben
cumplir y la otra es x + 2 menor que 0
x2 menor que cero restando dos de ambos
lados tenemos que x es menor que menos 2
de modo que aquí necesitamos tanto ésta
como ésta necesitamos que x sea menor
que 1 y que x x sea menor que menos 2
pero como lo hicimos aquí a la izquierda
pues estas dos condiciones se pueden
resumir simplemente a una x menor que
menos 2 porque cualquier número
cualquier número menor que menos 2
también es menor que 1 entonces lo voy a
poner aquí x es menor que menos 2 muy
bien menor que menos 2 con esto ya
resolvimos cada uno de los casos y
observa que aquí arriba hay un o este o
lo que quiere decir es que cualquiera de
estas dos ramas cualquiera de estos dos
caminos nos lleva a una solución
entonces este o lo podemos poner aquí
abajo así que las soluciones son o bien
x es mayor que 1 o bien x es menor que
menos 2 y eso podemos dibujarlo en la
recta numérica de la siguiente manera
aquí voy a poner la recta numérica por
aquí voy a poner el 0 por aquí que del 1
por acá que del -1 y por acá quede al
menos 2 entonces queda de la siguiente
manera una de las opciones es que x sea
mayor que 1 entonces aquí ponemos una
bolita para indicar que no agarramos el
1 pero marcamos toda esta región
esto es x mayor que 1 o
las otras x que funcionan son las x
menores que menos 2 aquí ponemos bolita
y tomamos esta región de acá
estas son las x menores a menos 2 muy
bien entonces eso sería nuestra solución
esta región de acá y esta región de acá
y en efecto en esta región tenemos
soluciones verdad por ejemplo si le
ponemos x igual a menos 3 nos queda
menos 3 lo voy a hacer aquí menos 3 - 1
dividido entre menos tres más dos y esto
es igual a menos 4 dividido entre menos
tres más dos o sea menos uno que es
igual a cuatro y en efecto esto es mayor
que
excelente entonces esto es la solución
pero te dije que había dos formas de
resolver este problema vamos a ver cómo
se hace de la segunda forma y ya tú
decides cuál te gusta más
déjame bajar
voy a resolver el problema aquí entonces
otra vez tenemos que x1 / x2 x + 2 es
mayor que 0 queremos resolver esto ahora
otra forma de pensar cómo resolverlo es
la siguiente como aquí tenemos una
fracción a lo mejor es buena idea
multiplicar a ambos lados de esta
desigualdad por x + 2 pero aquí hay que
tener cuidado cuando tenemos una
desigualdad si multiplicamos a ambos
lados por un número positivo entonces la
desigualdad se mantiene pero si el
número es negativo la desigualdad se
voltea y aquí no sabemos si x + 2 es
positivo o es negativo entonces vamos a
analizar ambas situaciones y con eso ya
vamos a tener información de si tenemos
que voltear esta desigualdad o no
entonces déjame otra vez hacer dos
caminos una posibilidad
una posibilidad es que x 2 x 2 lo voy a
poner aquí x + 2 sea mayor que 0 y la
otra posibilidad que voy a hacer de este
lado es que x + 2 x + 2 sea menor que
cero son las únicas dos posibilidades
verdad es imposible que x + 2 sea cero
porque sino esta expresión quedaría
indefinida bueno entonces sabemos que
aquí x + 2 es mayor que 0 de modo que
podemos concluir que x x es mayor que
menos dos simplemente restamos dos a
ambos lados de esta desigualdad pero
teniendo esta información ahora sí
podemos multiplicar esta expresión por x
+ 2 de ambos lados es decir aquí tengo x
menos uno dividido entre x más 2
y esto es mayor que 0 y como x + 2 es
positivo puedo multiplicar aquí por x2 y
acá también por x2
por x2 y esta desigualdad se conserva
bueno aquí éste se cancela con este 0 x
x + 12 0 y entonces esto nos dice que x
1 x menos 1 es mayor que 0 sumando uno
de ambos lados nos queda que x es mayor
que 1 y entonces qué sucede como podemos
resumir todo esto lo podemos decir así
en el caso en el cual x + 2 es mayor que
0 también necesitamos que x sea mayor
que 1 o sea si x es mayor que menos 2
necesitamos que x sea mayor que 1 y como
platicamos antes estas dos condiciones
se pueden resumir a una misma condición
basta con que x le gane a 1 con que x le
gane a 1 para que también x le gane a
menos 2 entonces todo este toda esta
rama se resume en que x es mayor que 1
vamos al otro lado en el otro lado hay
que ser cuidadosos porque ahora x + 2 es
menor que cero
de modo que x es menor que menos dos
simplemente restamos dos de ambos lados
pero ahora cuando multiplicamos por x
más 2
aquí tenemos x menos uno dividido entre
x2 por acá tenemos cero cero y vamos a
multiplicar por x más 2 cuando
multiplicamos por x + 2 como ahora es
negativo cambia el signo de la
desigualdad es decir si aquí tenemos un
mayor que aquí debe convertirse en un
menor que vale bueno simplificamos este
se cancela con este 0 por x + 12 0 así
que esto se resume a que x 1 x menos 1
es menor que cero y sumando uno de ambos
lados nos queda que x es menor que 1 de
esta forma en el caso en el que x + 2 es
menor que cero o sea x es menor que
menos 2 también necesitamos que x sea
menor que 1 pero claramente esta es una
condición más fuerte verdad todo el
número que es menor que menos 2 es menor
que 1 al revés no funciona por ejemplo
menos 1 es menor que menos 2
pero pero nos digamos otro número este
año menos 1 es menor que 1 pero no es
menor que menos dos exactamente entonces
esta condición si es más fuerte
de modo que en este caso podemos resumir
todo a x menor que menos 2 si dije eso
bien a ver menos 1 si es menor que 1
pero no es menor que menos 2 entonces
esta es la condición más fuerte
cualquier número menor que menos 2 es
menor que 1 y con eso tenemos nuestras
dos soluciones x es mayor que 1 y x es
menor que menos 2 creo que esté o no
lleva acento pero bueno vamos a dibujar
esto en la recta numérica lo voy a poner
por acá
ahí tenemos la recta aquí tenemos el 0
por aquí el 1 por aquí el menos 1 y por
acá el menos 2 está de acá nos dice que
tenemos que quedar a la izquierda de
menos 2 esta es una de las regiones
factibles o bien tenemos que elegir una
x en la otra región x mayor que 1
ponemos una bolita y elegimos esta
región que sigue para allá
indefinidamente si subimos y comparamos
es exactamente lo mismo verdad obtenemos
la misma respuesta así que realmente
pues depende de ti cuál de estas dos
formas de resolver es la que vas a
utilizar para resolver tus ejercicios
vale las dos llevan a la solución ya
cada quien elige cuál es más cómoda para
cada quien eso si cualquiera de las dos
necesita que pensemos con mucho cuidado
qué le sucede a los signos de las
desigualdades
cuando multiplicamos por por expresiones
positivas o negativas